hi-yah hey everybody
today we're super excited to have the
lovely Playboy Playmates Emilia talent
and Pamela warden here with us today
we're gonna play some super smash
brothers we love dad I got screwed
yesterday in the wheel of death so hope
I won't need to eat any more sticky buns
because beards and sticky buns mix
witnesses always the chattery of bet
Morosky leaning to the shop pass creeper
Jason O'Malley on the Whizzer twos he's
on point thank you don't need a like
hello I'm Matt Matt costo whoo back to
you all right there we go
let's do it you got I feel like you guys
are good at this game you guys are on
point Amelia it's like she brought her
up Pikachu for God so you think maybe
Jim good lord
talent on points tally and for those who
don't know in addition to being the
playmates we're also the gamers next
door that's right you can find them at
youtube.com slash gamer next door and
they have a hilarious own web series
that's right video and video that's
right that's right I've been on that and
what's your end yeah
Pamela hundred thirteen million town I'm
on point I know what she just did Pam
cut her hair I did I love it
I would love to grow my hair long but it
just gets bigger and bigger and bigger
like a dirty q-tip that's gross oh my
god now today it's gonna be interesting
because we like death there's gonna be
two losers for each thing so there's
gonna be a lot of we love death thing oh
man dude this egg move is killing you
all right so you guys wait this is
obviously not your first comic-con you
betcha this is my third the third Amelia
how many Comic Cons you got two
oh I like it up top up top I like it do
you like I was just high five in your
face okay and so what and how long you
down here for how are you dying for the
whole week yeah I love it dude
Amelia you are gonna get rocked this is
like no other comic convention it's
insane the smell this smell that's -
there's like a stale odor it's it's in
this area right here right now a stale
nerd odor all right hold on I always
wear a dumb shirt I get them on screen
comm by the way I've started making my
own my my favorite one I've made so far
which I can't wear in the office is
kisses on your pink parts I just want
mine my college roommate Tom Crowl
always signs all of his emails said
kisses on your big farts I'm like but
even like business emails you'd be like
dude listen like we got to figure out
like the percentage on this and he's
like kisses on your pink parts bro today
sure days don't grow up it's a trap it's
kind of like admiral ackbar ii I figure
it look at me just coming back and
grabbing that leg Oh
Pikachu dude I kind of hate you is it's
a mouse you're you're a pest you're a
household pests there we go here we go
and
oh boo take it you great hat though all
right Pam really death time I get a roll
yeah we both do we lost we both lost so
here we go oh you were Pikachu yeah you
didn't hear her say that I stolen no I
wasn't listening to either of you Carrie
you have to say all right Amelia it's
you and I that's doing no no you just we
don't spin separately weakest spin ever
what is that that looks like dressed to
impress
that looks like dressed you - that's
right that's right yeah look at that
yeah I love it
Star Wars a Star Wars travel pillow just
sleeps through the rest of thing all
right here we go that's good that's a
spin what do you know what is this Oh
get rich [ __ ] yeah I get to scratch up
a lot of ticket for people to lose yes
exactly
all right what should it be cool cat or
aces and eights any women named egg all
right here we go I'm just gonna don't
worry come on big money big money big
money by the way if you guys win any
money you get to keep it here I always
thought it would be hilarious if like so
if you guys want like a thousand dollars
you're like I'm on it here's like by
stream over I won nothing
nothing all right round two some of this
round two let's do it all right I just
want you guys to know I was letting you
off easy
you're the guest here so I want to make
you feel comfortable that's right that's
right that's chivalry's not dead
Jeffery's not dead and if I actually let
you guys win instead of really actually
trying that last round right here we go
I'm playing mark because I feel like
Marth that villager is so high yeah like
Rose her own stuff
she's exactly rice boy Aaron won nothing
just trying to be upbeat okay rice boy
damn boy yeah boy where's Roy he's our
boy Roy who's Roy yeah I think you're
talking about Conan who's that mister
person exactly well work what what sit
sit no no it was Roy who's Roy tera naam
my shirt is true don't go out the grub
pizza truck Amelia you pick that you
pick the thing you pick the thing my
fellow loser pick the thing what do tags
does this need by the way all right
let's put so many Sunni tanks take this
upper second I just want to show people
how many time this what are you doing
here that's trees you just wasted trees
sorry sorry they're coming back
by the way Melia I don't know if you can
see me leah is some awesome storm
trooper that's right yeah exactly in the
classes there's my storm trooper pose
Bruce Roy Oh DLC Kerry come on Erin oh
my god I don't have the hamstring you
guys do squats I don't have hamstring
strength for this this is like birthing
position we're all gonna have a baby
Super Smash Brothers baby edition come
on can we keep it up is the question
giant swords happening seriously you
guys must worked my legs are burning
right now
are they really yes hollinger deep focus
on upper body one of the motors I I
don't think this on body I'm more of a
lion guy I'm like read books I don't go
to the gym I have a weak core both
physically and emotionally
[Music]
this is this is really a dance party in
the back video I'm gonna let their legs
up looks like I got the strongest core
all those kneeling ab crunches you know
it's gamers next door on Team Coco I
like I do love streaming with people who
are better at streaming than me
we're with a pimp Lauren and Amelia
Talon for Playboy go to youtube.com
slash game right next door and follow
them at him Aloha 13
[Applause]
and meet an ad Amelia Talent all right
Pamela
spin it you got he from the bag of
mystery here we go no you pick this is
the bag of mystery it's a San Diego tote
bag I picked up at CVS all right here we
go
reach it reach it reach it make it good
make it good make it good yeah serious
pop that's what that mystery that's the
mystery part see it's got sprinkles on
it but you don't know that's right
there's no bananas in there there's no
bananas there's no the wheel of death is
actually the wheel hey what's a pop-tart
thank you it's a boxer they're super
ugly here we go what do we got dressed
to impress
pull something out Beth what do you got
by the way by the end of this we're all
going to be wearing like ridiculous
things all right here we go I got a
little veil got a little veil there you
go well you can take this over if you
should have where the Cockney angle or
just help me up perfect what if this
dream just turns into a makeover
we just make me over yeah exactly
exactly
potato Saurus mystery pop-tarts what was
that what was the thing it was
strawberry mystery solved the mystery
solved all right here we go all right
we've only played two rounds I'm wearing
a dumb hat
Amelia is wearing a travel pillow shams
Iggy Pop Tart and we've also I've also
already lost at the lottery so oh this
is choking me this is definitely gonna
be a problem
oh I'm sorry person who's worn a lot of
many hats with bail expert yeah oh
whoops sorry wait maybe we should change
your way to change I don't know what
girls you want yeah what guys what rules
what rules do we want here can we
increase the force pop-tarts are amazing
ice cream it's the best I can't eat
s'mores ice good I can't even play I
can't have carbs no cheat days I did
have a garbage brunch where you saw that
right for that I hadn't eaten anything
what Oh party foul that's a problem
we're not friends
I'm just sorry I'm sorry I'm just sorry
yeah why have a garbage brunch here
somewhere yeah I noticed I don't have
one because I'm not friendly you guys oh
my god that is the nerdiest and saddest
thing I've ever seen yes
Triforce all right we'll do it all right
here we go next time extreme no rule
street style Taco Bell says stalk so
stop the leg text okay stock I liked it
guys should we shoot low three high five
legs quickly Triforce legs do it get in
there perfect
all right pick Ike he's like the Mad
Hatter
all right stock I don't know what stock
here it's like wives who ever said only
play with one hand that's what we're
gonna do so good college chat already
thinks three stock only one hand rules
this is gonna be harder by the way I
think I'm gonna have an advantage cut
out because I'm playing with this I got
this bad boy
stripper output haha alright alright so
we're gonna start would you like this to
be like this well stock I mean plays
just like got like people living lives
or something all right I'm going
one-handed how is this gonna work
I'm gonna pay I'm going donkey oh whoops
all right are we good we're good not yet
play with feet all right Jim the dragon
chill out
blows feet maybe laughs we have to take
our shoes
oh right with your balls good one all
right are we ready zero you're right I'm
gonna have to like that's right I do
have small hands for my body though I've
got real small little [ __ ] hands here
we go let's see Yoshi's Island let's do
it it's a fun you know I feel like this
is the most San Diego in oh my god all
right here we go oh one hand oh my god
dude I don't she's wearing like her
workout gear applause whoa make sure by
the way [ __ ] her like leg is broken
look at that nobody can do that animated
Icke ulis black and white Kirby cool
hell yeah the only way we know how to do
rice boy says like Aaron's college
prison play with your pink parts that's
exactly what Tom crow would say play
with your pig parts I'm curl also first
one of my friends have a kid of course
that's the way it goes the dirtiest man
has don't blame the controllers
we go here we go oh dude I'm I maybe I
should play the one hand more often this
is awesome you're just off in a corner
punching things yeah well that's me
that's my wife it's also me in the
office that's a new sex move just
pasting honey this honey this isn't
uncomfortable shut up I'm just just head
buddy a girl's chest with my face
amazing
O'Malley thought that was holy I rarely
get such a great laugh out of a valley
but face ting apparently everybody on
the stream needs to look at everybody's
left hand right now because they're
probably jenkanz yeah left hands up left
hands up are you guys all right tingling
no oh whoops I hit pie Oh Oh get up
no no damn it wait which one of you feel
like this hat is impeding my game all
right so wait what are you guys doing
down here what do you guys got going on
you're filming stuff for your gamer next
door I'm really fun videos everybody
does
you know the sexy cosplayers yeah like
me right now yeah I'm sexy cosplay what
are you wanting to have his number one
you know one here being selfless you
want to be fair to everyone else what is
going on it's a weird jelly
oh god it's gross you should see a
doctor if you see by the way out there
you guys if you if your hat if you have
a Metroid somewhere in your body go see
a doctor that's awful so you guys are
doing cosplay but the test is the twist
is like everybody's expecting flavor to
be like
oh yeah sexy babes in cosplay but we're
gonna we're gonna objectify some dude
finally we're gonna find some Han dudes
and we're gonna talk about how hot they
are yes finally us guys got our moment
the objective being objectified son it's
a little sick bird my god my hand is
cramping up by the way hard Jigglypuff
is a knockoff of Kirby whoo Chauncey
Butler that's fightin words
them's fighting words Chauncey if you
guys don't know these fine ladies do a
great web series called gamer next door
that yours truly has been featured on
yeah pretty great multiple times
youtube.com slash gamer next door and
tweet at them and let them know what
game you want to see them play this is a
terrible idea whoever sent in the
chavies you played one hand god you're
it - also to blame then oh my god this
is the worst Roy boy who's yours truly
me dude when somebody says yours truly
they're talking about themselves I'll
decide gamer next door
good lord oh my god oh good lord
can they see our messages yes Catelyn
O'Brien we can see your messages
Maddie boy 194 is that named after the
kids next door no I think it's named
after those girl yeah girls next are
like that show like that because it's
also done by Playboy right that was the
name of the show girls next door playing
get plan girls
next our ah June the drug you think play
is good with using one hand that's right
I am good with using one hand and
exactly the way you're thinking which is
probably writing Civil War letters with
a quill pen that's the way I was yeah
could you mind out of the gutter or put
it back in the gutter plate light all
right Dylan Brown wants to see like you
why you know why cuz it's the tattoo so
every one of your text here got this
tattoo I don't think I'm thinking see it
say what it is
you wanna go you'll get distracted by
talking always what is it backwards
for the bag of mystery here we go
alright Pam hold the bag three hold the
bag shake it up shake the bag up shake
it up here we go
I die I go both hands in I dive in both
hands
cosmic brownie how many of your sisters
are in the chat today
- I love it oh you're like all 12
sisters I got a cosmic Friday what
happened
I'll be right way to follow nothing but
the best kind of wheel here for us I got
this object so you should have it like
all Jake to impress bang a mystery yeah
this is great
as we haven't eaten lunch yet pick again
pick it down thank you Dad
by the way you can feel that it's a
pop-tart that she still picked your
don't look it's a bag of mystery not a
bag of you pick what you want
there we go it's applesauce enjoy yes
I got a brownie you what's in my brownie
cosmic brownie huh that's right
he shares in his loss that's right to
feed never chasers okay oh man this is
awesome because I feel like I get to eat
stuffing for toddlers why are you just
eating
remember toddlers we're playing a video
game for work
amazing starve our applesauce is a fast
rose raise all right I believe you
[Music]
finally I don't make me talk about it
that's right what else oh you already
have grace mmm good now I can see oh
yeah right there
it's awesome I'm an old fart me too old
man but guys forever don't grow up it's
a trap these girls
Amelia toen Hamill Horton for Playboy
follow her and Amelia to add Amelia
Talent on everything right Instagram
Twitter
Friendster flimflam's
you just opened a flim flam's account
that's good flora flora go Hoffer you
know what I actually bought Fanny Gazoo
get calm and I thought it was really
funny I was like kind of messed up at a
bar I was like Oh Fanny kazoo and I
thought it was great so that I bought it
I just so I have Fanny Gazoo yeah there
you go when you open your League of
Shadows amazing okay cool that's good
idea how does that happen how do we do
how does that no one knows how to do
that how do we do that what does that
mean it means you more powerful no down
in the right corner you see the little
nothing oh and pick say we go
and now for the most exciting part of
this us putting in our names exactly so
the rest of the hour is gonna be us
spelling but whoever said put our names
in thank you that was a really good tip
thank you know the Chad goes better than
we do they're smarter play blinded play
blinded LAPD said by the way not
blindfold and blinded like we should
permanently blind ourselves just for
this it's me I'm gonna be myself that's
donkey oh wait that's cool are you
kidding me no can't sit with us that's
right this is divine yeah but that's
merely you'll be more powerful tell your
mom I said hi
tell her to join the check but Pam's got
half her family in the jab hi Pam's
sisters and mom are you guys ready are
you asleep it's a handicap Amelia's just
like Talan that Crazy's name ever best
name ever here we go
Amelia she plays the Wii Fit trainer so
I'm going to take the handicap objet
we're trying to I've never played on
handicaps of course I don't know I don't
know how it is you know it makes it
harder all right well here oh yes No
whoa talk tough talk all right I mean
would you want to do it should we do it
doing this she's doing something some of
this teleporting on
oh my god Amelia's warface here we go
let's do it ready to fight I'm in fine
20% handicap where you want to play by
the way my fail
I've got a handicap - it says Vail brand
I can watch it your your hat bottle yeah
hey everyone how's it going final just
this yeah more lies all right there we
go
zebra cakes you know what I'm Casto I
don't know if they receive Oh unfair at
least you're playing with two hands this
time oh you guys are dead this is my boy
right here I thought you guys have I
just got a 3ds it's amazing
did you bring it I didn't bring it I
don't have time to play games here at
Comic Con says while playing games here
at comic-con you bring you bring it to
you in the street asses oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna have an intern that's a lie I'm
gonna have an intern go all the way back
to LA go to my house we threw all the
garbage and the pizza boxes in my
bedroom of which there are many because
that's where I eat pizzas in bed and
then get my 3ds and the charger and then
bring it back and then we'll Street okay
it'll be worth it cuz I won't have to do
it I'm an intern I'll be an intern you
can have one of ours they're really nice
yeah they're great
Oh guys we got we got a lot of good
interns some insurance for Michigan
State by the way my alma mater oh yeah
Spartans shout out if I cared about
sports that would mean something boopsy
says I'd do that whoo see no offense but
how am I gonna get you my keys to get to
my apartment oh god yes he's back
oh this gray-haired monkey is just
taking you to to town slash losing
really bad that's actually exactly right
that's exactly right I hope you guys are
just joining us today we're hanging out
with Playboy Playmates at gamer
next-door hosts Amelia tally - Pamela
Horton II follow them on social media
oh you son of a [ __ ] don't follow me on
social media you son of a [ __ ] follow
them at a million seven at fab low
horrid thirteen and youtube.com slash
gamer next door where's your next video
coming out ladies do you put them out
every week what oh my good gravy Monday
Wednesday and Friday that's awesome what
what games you you guys went to e3 yeah
yeah we're actually one of the our next
game play videos to come out is going to
be working
if anybody plays I'm on Gilgamesh I have
a right now a in between the white mage
I'm working on my dark knight there we
go you're all full I just got a PC
finally second place at what should meet
with our first PC game I get into what
oh dude I don't know if I could do that
hey I said like come here come here how
about some fire scarecrow
yeah oh yeah [ __ ] oh that's University
of Michigan and they are on there the
rivals to Michigan State but here's the
thing
I don't care about sports B I grew up in
in our review of em astronomy none and
and so it doesn't it doesn't matter to
me I'm just a Michigan boy I don't care
whatever thing who is Pikachu yeah
whatever
good job that was great Oh tag back
Pam's got a spin okay I love what you're
done oh are you done I was getting
people to watch this I like it
dress yes yeah visors love it
hot a soccer mom in the game here we go
dress to impress bring it out bring it
out me I guess I can't hold on I'm gonna
have to take this off this is I look
like submarine and can't hardly wait
[Laughter]
that's right yeah our Jenna Knoxville
about to get into like a poo Laden
something or other about to go to some
Alice in Wonderland poo party oh my god
here we go
I look like a psychopath I look like a
splicer for Bioshock these eyes are
gonna start sweating real quick top top
talent I like it it already gives you an
automatic handicapper winning
interesting wait maybe we turn handicaps
off how do we feel about that yeah
handicap tomorrow also should we play
with more light do we like the lives
thing or to be like exciting because
that's Oh take stock off time hi two
minutes two minutes one man oh my god
you girls cray yeah what she ordered
fish fillet here we go boots with the
fur mic - I'm gonna classic Mario what
let's do it's oh here we go America
American Mario's America
American mario here we go oh wait
media tagger is a great idea let's
choose people for each other all right
here we go all right all right here we
go I'm gonna pick who's the shittiest
person oh wait what am I doing here
these but I'm already starting to fog up
this is terrible that's scuba diving I
think if I spit in these goggles I'm
just I'm sorry like if they're spit who
I'm green peach great butts all right
let's do it right how do you need a
different hat Pikachu ah pro caliber try
to play drunk goggles on what do you
think these are a week's bit trainer ooh
I like it
Wii Fit trainer actually has that like
one of the most annoying that weird ball
thing I hate that big country says have
you ever streetpassed the Playboy
Mansion do other people do other
playmates are they gamers just you pass
each other and that's it oh thanks other
eye are there any other planning we
played with what was your name Raquel
poplin who is she Cheryl again she was
like screamed the whole time she was
afraid of she was just very scared but
we have her on because she's one of
those ones where she doesn't know how to
play but she's adorable yes she's a dork
so adorbs and the coolest people the
people that can make fun of themselves
absolutely and she was all about making
fun of rice boy finally we fit trainer
you're getting your wish rice boy Wii
Fit trainer is in the game oh wait
that's right I'm green peach oh you're
gonna bout to feel some fury from green
peach yeah that's right don't let this
dress fool you
when you keep under there I don't know
harsh words just [ __ ] what happened it
look like ski goggles yeah they feel
like ski goggles they're very hot give
me that give me that look at me just
floating around that's [ __ ] Oh God
yes all I need now is a fancy bowtie
stealthy Daleks eyes yeah well that's
probably coming next
okay all right let's do it oh my god
we're gonna run out then we're just
gonna start taking bets close you got it
yeah oh man here we go
[ __ ] that's getting kreo I lost two damn
it Oh
bag of mystery eat for the bag of
mystery god damn it
all right here we go hold it Wow I'm
going in go dance yeah what is this
oatmeal cream pie oh man this is great
oh no I don't care I don't care
five-minute rule
ruin our Beach yeah I do have diseases
look at me how can I not be Jesus mental
diseases you're talking like you're
drunk I'm drunk I really that mature
like six months party foul exactly oh my
god five second not five minutes while I
play the five-minute rule
because I have low health state oh okay
I'll be serious for a second what let's
say you leave a piece of pizza out on
the counter how gonna fight him okay I
think I'm gonna have to fight oh you
gotta fight him I can't I can barely see
through these steamed up dog playing the
maneuver snap okay yeah somebody beat
him someone says we'll play it will play
the miiverse next whoever said well you
want to see whatever in the chat says
they want to say his plan the miiverse
map will play then beavers back next but
we do what you want
we are your puppets for which to pull
the strings and we dance I mean look at
me
this is seriously [ __ ] you that's right
I think since Amelia relinquished potato
Soros is like wow I can't let the guy go
free I know from experience Pro caliber
you know what we Team Coco wear the
goggles don't breathe that's our new
motto
that lady comes peeking in hate that
lady get out of your mom you guys are
just joining us we are streaming today
with the lovely Playboy Playmates
Familia talent a Pamela Wharton from
gamer next door you can find their web
series youtube.com slash gamer next door
or as Pamela says youtube.com forward
slash gamer next door
imma wha do free-for-all that's like Don
Pardo Saturday no all random all right
all random how do we do rent oh here we
go let's do I can't see [ __ ]
yeah it's from our old Cossack offensive
all random let's do it who's picking
who's got it you got it
you're saying all random and you're
picking it I can't even see who is that
who's talking who is that millions that
you that you million your hair is on
point today about well done how long
that take well I just realized we all
have our names above our characters so
we should know immediately try it out
celebration the Princess Leia thing I
even have
so it's wait so wait a save your dress
is a stormtrooper but your Princess Leia
oh you know what wait you are you
remember when they save her from the
start does she dress up like a
stormtrooper or know that she does right
when when Luke and Han save her from the
interrogation because then you're fit
you're like the most specific cosplay
you're like that five minutes she
dresses you're right that's to your
point but still I can't see myself
because I can't see through my own filth
it's building up on the inside of these
goggles what happened ah let's do it
alright I finally won I don't have to
spin the wheel thank God
ace trainer has deserved video game you
guys aren't awful at know the answer I'm
terrible at everything dressed to
impress what do we got oh it's a cup
alright
there's more than one cup in there give
her both cups there you go you get both
cuffs you want to undo it dude you look
like a gladiator you look like a really
sleepy gladiator he's about to go on a
plane yeah and you're in the empire an
empire gladiator goes on a plane land a
mess what are you guys looking for the
most - at Comic Con what are the best
play best cosplays have you seen so far
one of the best pathways you get my buns
perfect and I like okay so I haven't
really seen them
possibly he's caused most of the
cosplayers I'm coming till the afternoon
yes but one thing I have seen is tons
and tons and tons of guys moving and
like taking pictures with Amelia our
cosplay but but the first the first time
someone's like Pamela really Italian
take a picture with you no actually I'm
ok with that
I'm totally ok maybe she's jealous that
your I love it I saw a great Last
Airbender last night Oh fantastic head
shaved the job you mean like avatar an
avatar yes no no the the yeah with the
blue arrow and stuff it was fantastic I
also saw a really cool splicer TSM lost
voices damn girl on the left
damn girl thank you thanks I'm a guy by
the way also I'm on the left but guess
not if you're watching glasses over the
face mask pro gamer it's it's not her
it's not her first time wearing a mask
with glasses hell yeah
dunker up his yeah don't grow up it's a
trap god bunch shirt here we go
Oh his name is Aang not avatar no I
think it was densha attention the guy
with the blue arrow on his head who my
finger at the home of the avatars
happened ah see
he was orange also he had orange like an
orange cape like I feel like some of
your knowledge on like comic and it's
terrible it's just like you opened the
first page of a book and you saw things
and
like well I I don't know a lot about
like that I do know a lot about other
stuff what are some moves this guy there
we go yeah hey you guys want to see our
secret handshake here it is flail around
oh my god no no don't break the seal
don't break the seal I've also been
drinking beer don't break the seal here
we go
alright I'm gonna play I'm gonna play
the prettiest girl in the game to you
yes so underrated hottest playmate ever
there we go
what about me guys by the way for your
next centerfolds if you want to borrow
the goggles in the Hat okay go for it
I'll own it yes oh yeah oh I'm gonna
play Wario yeah where's worried good
show good show
where's my wife naked show woo get sexy
I'm gonna go uh-oh
let's go pink Wario sensitive Wario I
call him your commander Brian you so hot
yeah the goggles people in there I like
how everybody knows about you having a
meal you're super hot right now are all
either related or no oh yeah there we go
Aaron's sucks you see I'm getting some
support from the chat dude finally
finally for once I'm getting since we're
working the play don't break the seal
seriously don't break the seal all right
here we go
what about Luigi's Mansion you guys like
that's right
barely barely see anything shrek is
super hot yeah I don't know I feel like
Shrek though first probably pretty good
lover probably pretty good lover in bed
you know what it's why you even do
oh he farts right yeah oh no he's also
got like a oh wow he's also got again
he's also got like a thing where I come
on should I get into Final Fantasy I
don't know anything about Final Fantasy
here's a question if it's final final
fantasy why do they keep releasing
sequels great question for the
Expendables
oh no no no or what was it these are all
good cos in theory these are all good
oh no oh wait it's very much I hesitated
I thought I was like you know fast and
furious the last ride this is really the
last ride someone seriously this ride is
going on forever all right eat for the
bag of mystery thank God thank God oh my
god I got two hands that I come out with
pretzel thing
hi pigs alright
the hell is this
no that's the same thing I just had
there we go be jerky beef jerky let's do
it well you spin you spit it's been I
think we only got time for one more game
after this is that dress dress dress to
impress oh my god
last match here we go so if you're just
joining us where the hell have you been
hey Playboy Playmates from gamer next
door go to youtube.com this is so spicy
oh my god
I can't well I gotta take this out of
prison youtube.com slash gamer next door
add Emilia talent and at pan Lauren 13
on both Twitter and Instagram and
flim-flam if you guys are on the app
flim-flam which you all should be on
flip flip and fluid floorboards both
floorboards floorboards that's really
fun to say floorboards all right go go
go you go Glen Coco yeah me versa you
lied to us okay fine we'll play in the
movers already ready to go this is Lasky
alright I'll soak it up she'll get up I
can't immediate verse here we go
alright you guys wanted it you're
getting it me versus naked shulk I know
they're getting me verse you want to
make it show you got naked show you want
to be verse you got me verse let's go
Mennonite cell Marquis
Oh God are you just looking around oh
yeah
looks like a little kid though so fine
with it
hey you were the one that was worst
Yvonne and he was like supposed to be 10
years old ebox mad at night yeah boy
[Music]
Pamela marry me please somebody said he
said that twice oh nice
well the answer is yes and I'll be
presiding in this outfit yeah I'm
answering for you
I'm your marriage adviser all marriage
proposals have to go through me for both
Amelia and Pamela and I will take bribes
by the way I have your mayor you have
your marriage manager I will take bribes
Daniel what the we was one of the best
Nintendo consoles agreed although loving
my new 3ds oh you got the new new 3ds
yeah yeah they're all fake you know what
if it didn't happen first it doesn't
count
no one cares no one cares you can't say
marry me now it doesn't matter ah well
done fellas
all right Mary Blaine last man last this
is the last sad spin for me
what is it dress trust you don't even
have anything else
oh yeah double goggles here we go
all right human life means nothing let's
do it jumbo goggles yep there we go oh
my god yeah I caught I call these
goggles wow this is really uncomfortable
all right I know they're lying though
because they would have said it first
they cared there we go eat from the bag
of misery one one last thing for the
road
oh there we go that's the best thing in
the bag all right okay thank you to the
lovely Playboy Playmates
Pamela Horton and Amelia challenge you
can find them at at Pamela gordon13 on
Twitter and Instagram and add a million
talent please watch their web series
it's gamer next door youtube.com slash
camera next row they're gonna be around
comic-con shooting all kinds of stuffs
if you see him say hi and of course we
here at Conan are airing a show every
night at 11 on TBS ashtag Conan con you
want us to see something and we will be
streaming every day including tomorrow
at noon with another special guest thank
you ladies for coming
[Applause]
you